G
IN HOTEL ROOMS AND THE
HOMELESS PROBLEM IN
SAN FRANCISCO IS WORSE BECAUSE
IF YOU PAY FOR SOMETHING YOU GET
MORE OF IT. THE SAN FRANCISCO
SAY THIS IS HAPPENING. JASON
RANTZ THE WEST COAST RESPONSE
WAS LOOKING INTO THIS IN SEATTLS
TONIGHT, HEY, JASON.
>> I WOULD ARGUE THAT DISASTER
IS AN UNDERSTATEMENT. SO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELESSNESS AND
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING PUT
$160 MILLION IN A PROGRAM TO
PREVENT STOMACH WITH THESE
HOTELS INTO SUPPORTIVE HOUSING D
BY VARIOUS NONPROFITS AND
PUTTING A TOTAL OF 166 FATAL DRG
OVERDOSES BETWEEN 2020-2021 AT
THESE HOTELS. THE HOMELESS HAVE
BEEN VIOLENT THERE. WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT ASSAULTS,
STABBINGS, THREATS TO KILL
STAFF. ON TOP OF THAT SOME OF
THE HOTEL TOTAL SHAMBLES.
BATHROOMS AND ELEVATORS DON'T
WORK. SERIOUS RAT INFESTATION,
ROACHES EVERYWHERE. ONE HOMELESS
WOMAN PITCHED THE TENT INSIDE OF
HER ROOM TO KEEP THE RATS AND
THE BUGS OUT. THE GOAL FOR THESE
HOTELS IS TO GET HOMELESS PEOPLE
INTO INDEPENDENT HOUSING BUT
THEY CHECKED OVER 500 PEOPLE
THAT LEFT THE PROGRAM PEER THEY
FOUND A QUARTER OF THEM DIED,
20% RETURN TO HOMELESSNESS AND
27% LEFT THE AREA AND COULDN'T
BE TRACKED AT ALL. ONLY A
QUARTER OF THEM GOT INTO HOUSING
AGAIN APPEAR THOSE ARE LIVING
WITH FAMILY OR GOING INTO OTHER
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING PROGRAMS.
NOW, THANKS TO MAYOR LONDON
BREED AGAINST AN OVERSIGHT
COMMISSION, THE PROBLEMS HAVE
ONLY GOTTEN WORSE. SINCE THE
CITY CREATED THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELESSNESS, HOMELESSNESS
INCREASED TO 56% ACCORDING TO
THE CHRONICLE. NOW, DESPITE THAT
EARLIER THIS MONTH, WE GOT
MAYOR BREED PURCHASING ANOTHER
HOTEL. AS YOU POINT OUT FROM A
DIFFERENT VERSIONS BASICALLY OF
STRATOSPHERE HAPPENING AROUND
THE COUNTRY. SO LAST MONTH AND
LOS ANGELES HOMELESS PEOPLE IN
ENCAMPMENT MOVED TO FOUR-STAR
HOTEL AND HERE, IN SEATTLE, THEY
ARE SPENDING TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO BUY HOTELS FOR LOW
BARRIER PERMIT HOUSING. THE MOST
RECENT ONE IS JUST FEET AWAY
FROM A SCHOOL. AND IN NEW YORK
THEY PUSHED $100 MILLION IN TWO
HOTEL CONVERSION PROGRAM AND
STALLED BECAUSE OF ZONING SO THE
DEMOCRATS, LET'S PUSH A BILL TO
MAKE IT EASY TO CREATE THESE
HOMELESS HOTEL. THEY ARE FAILING
EVERYWHERE THEY GO AND IT'S
NOT JUST LOCAL DOLLARS TO YOUR
POINT, THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
IS PUTTING A LOT OF DOLLARS
THROUGH COVID FUNDS.
>> Tucker: IT IS ALSO CRUEL